how would you characterize describe your
own worldview I call myself a Social
Democrat it was my commitment I was
brought up in a Social Democrat family
and I go on this I wanted liberal miss
too many things in it Social Democrat
has obviously some the liberal ideals
but if you ask me about sort of a
general term to describe which I would
say yeah social democrat but without
much social democracy anymore no me know
what we see is that there was an attack
that was the heydays of social democracy
after the move the Werthan really the
most successful years and I think that
what we see now is a decline so
obviously of a of the organized labor I
mean because of the nature of thing that
the industry that globalization zone to
meet 200 million people join the
workforce in the world silver in
countries that weren't integrated in
global was and we are now in the mid of
changes so social democracies challenge
posed by the neoliberals and by people
on the way far left nice but I still
think that the only sensible the only
sensible world view in terms of
socialism is social democracy I mean in
Scandinavia said I think Scandinavia the
Netherland when it was sort of a god I
think those are good places to look it
but why face why is there this ongoing
struggle for men guard too
create a just society what because
justice site is a good thing so you try
to bring it I mean I I see all the
reasons to bring a just society it was
by is it so difficult to succeed or
because they're people who lose by
having a just society they both many
people powerful people will lose a great
thing if there is a justice I the point
is where they have enough people like it
was destined interesting justice that's
a problem just every thurs wine
injustice it's very easy to explain why
justice is an outlet why people will be
motivated to bring about justice enough
be and that's very hard actually you
don't have enough Italy where power is
dispur I mean to concentrate power is
very hard and in order to when you
concentrate power you can you gain lots
of things that you don't want to share
with others so the people gain power
usually create a league office of
certain kinds and I think what used to
be called there that I won't love the
oligarchy I think there is a great need
to safely that's actually what you save
in lot of a gala tarian egalitarian
parties and egalitarian ideologies that
once they got the power their commitment
is gone because the privilege is over
the power is there is concentrated quite
to share it with others